طيب سيد عثمان هذه صور لتحليق الطيران
الحربي في سماء الخرطوم قبل قليل قال
الجيش السوداني بان القوات الجويه تنفذ
ضربات تجاه الدعم السريع
يشكل ردعا لها اذا هذه الصور صور لتحليق
الطيران الحربي في سماء الخرطوم ايضا
الاشتباكات كما اشار ضيفي تقع في
ربما خطوط تماس متقاربه جدا بين الطرفين
وكما
قال مراسلنا قبل قليل بالاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه سواء كانت في الخرطوم او حتى
هناك في مروي كان هناك اشتباكات بين
الطرفين لا نعلم الى اي مدى قد تستمر هذه
الاشتباكات كذلك
المعلومات الوارده هي متضاربه من الطرفين
من سيطره الطرفين قوات الدعم السريعه تقول
انها قد سيطرت على القصر الرئاسي ومقر
اقامه البرهان بينما قال الجيش بعد ذلك من
ان لا صحه
لهذه الادعاءات لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات